>> Betsy Peterson: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Betsy Peterson: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I want to welcome you to the
Library of Congress here today.
I'm Betsy Peterson,
and I'm the Director
of the American Folklife
Center, which is a relative,
or I guess you might say,
the Veterans History Project.
The two organizations or divisions
work very closely together.
Thank you for coming and
for our wonderful Book Talk,
featuring Cecilia Garcia-Akers,
who will discuss her new book,
"The Inspiring Life of
Texan Hector P. Garcia."
Before we get started though, I
would like you to take a moment
of silence to honor the memory of
another member of the Garcia family,
Cecilia's uncle and veteran of
our country, Dr. C.P. Garcia,
who passed away last month
on Sunday, April 24th.
He was the last surviving brother
to Dr. Hector P. Garcia and,
like his brother, he too also served
his community in medical practice,
Civil Rights activism, and as a
member of the American GI Forum.
So, if we could just
have a moment of silence.
[ Silence ]
Thank you.
Now, the Veterans History Project
would like to take a moment
to thank the co-sponsors
of this event,
and we have a couple here today that
we're really pleased to recognize,
the Library's Office of
Equal Employment Opportunity
and Diversity Programs and the
Library's Hispanic Initiative,
which is a two-year
initiative headed
by the Hispanic Working Group
here at the Library with the aim
of increasing awareness among
the US Hispanic community
about the Library's programs,
services, collections,
and career opportunities, in
addition to increasing programming
about the US Hispanic experience.
And now I'd like to talk a
little bit more specifically
about our guest of honor.
Morning, Corpus Christi Texas,
Cecilia Garcia-Akers is the daughter
of Dr. Hector P. and
Wanda F. Garcia.
She holds a bachelor's degree in
biology from St. Mary's University
in San Antonio and a
graduate from the University
of Texas Medical Branch
in Galveston, Texas,
with a degree in Physical Therapy.
Currently, she is in private
practice in San Antonio, Texas,
where she specializes
in geriatric orthopedics
and neuromuscular rehabilitation.
Her first job was as a medical
assistant to her father,
the man we are here to commemorate
today, Dr. Hector P. Garcia,
and she worked with
him for ten years prior
to completing her studies
in physical therapy.
She has served on the Texas State
Board of Physical Therapy Examiners
and as Board Chair, appointed
by Texas Governors Mark
White and Ann Richards.
Among many other professional
accomplishments, in 2012,
Ms. Akers founded the Dr. Hector
P. Garcia Memorial Foundation
and is presently serving
as Board President
and Chair of the Foundation.
In 2015, she delivered
a presentation titled,
"Dr. Hector P. Garcia as a
Father, Physician, and Role Model,"
at the Texas State Historical
Association's Annual Meeting
in Corpus Christi.
Just last week, on May 12,
she received her most
recent recognition,
which is very relevant I
think to today's presentation,
and certainly in line
with her father's legacy.
She received the American
GI Forum of South Texas
"Standing Up for Veterans" Award.
So, congratulations on that.
Currently, she resides
in San Antonio, Texas,
with her husband Jimmy, who
is also here with us today
and is the proud mother and
grandmother to her daughter Melina
and to her two grandchildren,
Savannah and Noah.
The book Ms. Garcia-Akers will
discuss is her first book,
"The Inspiring Life of
Texan Hector P. Garcia,"
which is published by History Press.
It was released on April 4, 2016,
and it's already in
its second printing.
Very impressive!
After the discussion,
please stay for a Q and A
and to see Ms. Garcia-Akers donate
her father's original World War II
photographs to the Veterans History
Project, which collects, preserves,
and makes accessible the personal
accounts of American War Veterans
so that future generations may
hear directly from veterans
and better understand
the realities of war.
You may also purchase
a copy of the book
and get Ms. Garcia-Akers'
autograph as you leave.
So, please stay around afterwards,
but in the meantime, please join me
in welcoming our guest,
Cecilia Garcia-Akers.
Ms. Aker.
[ Applause ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Well,
thank you all for being here.
I'm just overwhelmed to be
here at the Library of Congress
and discussing my father, my beloved
father, and his accomplishments.
And first of all, I want
to introduce my family
that made the trip
here to support me.
My husband Jim Akers is here,
and my sister, Susie Garcia,
and her partner Nell
Hahn [assumed spelling].
[ Applause ]
I want to thank the Library of
Congress for hosting me today.
I just never expected such
a historical day for me
and my father's legacy
and to have written a book
about my father was
certainly not planned.
After I gave my lecture
in Corpus Christi in 2015
at the Historical Commission, I
got a call from the History Press,
and they asked me,
"Have you ever thought
about writing a book
about your father?"
And I said, "Of course not."
I mean, I had not even
thought about that.
So, with a lot of help
from the publisher,
which they gave me tremendous
help because they helped me
with the author proposal and how
to fill it out and send it in.
Well, after I sent it in, two
days later I got a contract.
So, I think they just thought
it was a good thing to do,
and then they were so kind that
they only gave me six months
to write 33,000 words.
So, we were struggling.
We were sweating bullets the
whole time, but it was fun.
And then we had, we submitted 75
photographs, and they accepted 70.
So, I think it was just a
gift from above, a gift,
and it's given me an opportunity to
give my gift to everyone who wants
to know about my father and his
struggles and to all the veterans
that he took care of for 50
years and how he changed the face
of this country by the laws
that he made sure were passed
in Civil Rights, in education, the
schools that he helped desegregate
in Texas, and for people not
to forget how important his
advocacy was for this country,
for us to have a better
America today.
And several people have told me
that this book is perfect timing
for what is going on
in this country,
and we can never forget
our struggles,
and we have to teach our
children what the struggles are
and how they're kind of coming back.
So, I don't want my father's
life to ever be forgotten
because he deserves better,
and I think the book,
I wanted to write the book, not
his historical analysis of his life
because that has been done
by two previous authors,
but a daughter's perspective on his
struggles, his personal struggles,
which he had, he had many,
and the family struggles
and the financial impact
on his work,
what it did for his family,
my mother's struggle.
My mother, if you think
about my mother, Wanda,
she raised four children all on
her own, and people are really,
if you have a historical figure
like Dr. Hector P. Garcia,
they don't realize, people don't
realize the struggles that go along
with his advocacy, and I
think that we can all learn
from him that he never gave up.
He went from one thing to another.
He just never stopped.
He never stopped.
He was never satisfied
with his work.
And so I'm hoping that the book
kind of opens people's eyes
and to understand that, you know,
he, he made this a better country.
And because we are talking about
the Veterans History Project,
I wanted to share with you a little
bit, my own research on my father,
life, especially in the military
because it was certainly
interesting.
And I knew nothing because, as
my father with his humility,
he never talked about his struggles.
He never came home and talked
about what he had done.
He never talked about his struggles
when he was growing
up, but he had many.
He came to this country
when he was three years old,
settled in Mercedes, Texas, to
escape the Mexican Revolution.
They had ten children.
His father and mother
had ten children.
Out of the seven surviving children,
six of them became medical doctors.
Now, if you think about that in
the 1940s and 1950s, Dr. Hector,
Dr. J.A. and Dr. Cleo all
went to the University
of Texas Medical Branch
in Galveston.
The other children went to
Medical School in Mexico.
But there were six practicing
physicians in that one family.
Now, you wonder how,
how did that happen?
Well, he had a very strict father.
He went to segregated
schools, so his parents,
his father would take the
children into the basement
and teach them things like history,
English, things that they needed
to know because he wanted
his family to succeed.
So, that's how they got it done.
I mean, this is what we have to
teach our children, you know,
you're going to have struggles,
you have to educate yourself.
And growing up in a
segregated school system,
creating six medical
doctors, is really unheard of,
especially two of them were women.
So, that was something.
I think that when he
went to UT, Galveston,
that was really eye-opening
because we heard not too long ago,
when we were in Galveston
a few weeks ago in April,
that my father was the first
Mexican American graduating
from their school in
1940, the first.
So, think about, he got into 1936.
They only accepted one
Mexican a year, and it was him.
Pretty remarkable life, you know, he
had to have top grades to do that.
But sadly, after that big
accomplishment, no school in Texas
or hospital in Texas would accept
him for his residency, none.
So, he ended up in Omaha, Nebraska,
St. Joseph's Hospital,
Creighton University.
And I remember this story, telling
me that, oh, they sent some doctors
down to Galveston, and we really
liked them, so we decided to go
with them all the way to
Omaha in the freezing weather,
and from South Texas this did not
go well for him, going into Omaha.
But the truth was no one
would take him, no one.
So, he went there for his two years.
He then got called to
active military duty.
He had, we found out in our research
that he had lied about his age
to get into the Citizens'
Military Training Corps
when he was 15 years old.
And I'm sure what happened with
his good looks and his, you know,
tall stature that they asked him,
"Okay, how old are you, Hector?"
And he said, "Sixteen."
Okay, they wrote it down,
and "Where were you born?"
And he said, "Mercedes,"
and they wrote it down.
That's exactly what's on
his separation papers,
and we know none of that was true.
We knew he was born in Mexico,
and he was born in 1914,
so he lied about his age
by one year just to get in.
So, he was trying to escape poverty.
He was, you know, trying to
prepare for the rest of his life.
So, when he got called to active
military duty in 1940 after he,
1942, he was already had
been a commissioned officer.
So, when he got called to
active military duty in 1942,
he had tried to get several
promotions in the army.
We had letters that his application
had been lost two times and,
you know, then they changed
their policy that unless he was
on active duty he couldn't
get promoted.
I mean, it was just one thing after
another, one thing, one thing.
So, did he give up?
No, he did not.
He did not give up.
He never gave up, and so he finally
got promoted to Captain in 1942,
after being First Lieutenant.
And in 1946, he was awarded Major.
It was after he separated from
the army, first part of 1947 is
when he was awarded Major.
So, he separated from
the army in 1946,
but his Major classification
didn't come
until after he was out of the army.
So, I mean, I think that you look
at one man and his struggles,
and he just kept trying and
trying to beat the system and work
through it and to get
what he felt was due.
And I think we can all
look at him and think, boy,
what kind of person was this?
And I, I didn't know anything.
I didn't know any of this
because he never talked about it.
So, I got all his military records
and all his papers, and I had so,
I gained so much more respect
for him because he knew,
he knew there was a better life
there, and he wanted to move
up into the -- he loved
being in the army.
And then the other thing
we found about my father,
I know everybody's going to
freak out when I tell you this,
but you know he went to
segregated schools in Mercedes.
He went to UT Austin,
graduated top 10% of his class.
Then he went to medical school
in Galveston, and then he went
to Omaha, and then he took care of
tens of thousands of soldiers all
over this world, all over the
world, for the United States
as a medical doctor, and he
was not even a US citizen.
It's pretty amazing!
He did not become a US citizen until
November 7, 1946, after he got out.
We always wondered, Jim and I always
wondered why he married my mother
in 1945 in June.
My older sister was born there
in Italy, but they stayed there.
They stayed there for a
year, and now we found
out he wasn't even a citizen.
So, I think he waited
until last minute to do it.
You know, we don't really know why,
but I think sometimes I think his
parents never became citizens.
They immigrated here legally, but
they never did become a citizen.
So, I don't know, if that
had some influence on him,
but he finally did it, but
everybody's kind of shocked
that a non-citizen would work their
way up and get educated and get
in the US Army, and he was so, you
know, it was so difficult for him,
and he was not even a
citizen of this country.
And I think this says
a lot for immigrants
that are coming here
and want a better life.
I think he's a role model for that.
You know, he was just a great
physician, and I think that working
with him for ten years taught me
so many things and how he took care
of patients and how he, you
know, he never turned anyone away
because they didn't have money.
He never said no, if you can't
pay me, you'll come back later.
That never happened, and he
was just a great physician,
and he cared so much about every
single one of his patients that came
in and all the children that came
in that he was able to take care of,
and that is just a part of my life
that at the time I did not
recognize how important it was going
to be for me.
Now that I'm in healthcare
and think about all the things
that he taught me that I could
never learn from a book, you know,
that was just a great ten years.
And then, as I got older, and we
would talk on the phone about cases
and medical cases and
how patients were doing,
and he would ask my opinion once
in a while, and I was like, "Oh,
my God," you know, "he's
asking my opinion,"
on things that he was working on.
So, that was very important to me.
He was very disappointed I did
not finish and become a doctor
like he was, and it took a long time
for me to realize and get over that,
but he was very disappointed that
I did not go to Medical School,
and I became a physical therapist.
He, and I know that, but
then he finally accepted it.
It took him about eight years,
but he finally accepted it
and embraced it, and I think he just
finally understood what physical
therapists do, and it's
so important, you know,
in rehabilitating a person's life
and getting them back on their feet.
And I think all he thought
anyone could be was a doctor
or an attorney, and
that was his mindset
because he had all these
siblings that were physicians,
and so it was a struggle for
us, you know, when I decided
to become a physical therapist.
But I am happy that I
chose that profession
because here I am working, and one
of the things he did teach me is
to be independent, and so
that's, that's what I did.
So, I think that we need to
look at my father's life as far
as not only his accomplishments
but his struggle,
and that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted people to finally realize,
and my understanding is not too
many books have been written
on a historical figure from
a daughter's perspective.
So, I think this is a new thing.
So, I hope that you all enjoy
the book and you like it,
and the book is comprehensive
in that it talks about many
of the events and his
accomplishments,
the things that influenced him,
and I talk, there's a chapter there
on the death of my brother, and
most people didn't even know I had
a brother.
So, I talk about that
and the influence
on my brother's death on him.
And then there's a chapter on
my mother, her influence on him,
and even though she struggled a lot
because my father did not know how
to save money, that's for sure,
so all his money went to causes,
his causes, the American GI
Form, anybody who needed money.
If they couldn't come in
and pay him, you know,
he would see them for free.
He would give, I heard from a man
the other day that said he went
in for his physical
to go to college,
and my father handed him $100 to
help him to get to Del Mar College
in Corpus Christi, and this is
just the way he was, you know.
He didn't care if he
didn't have any money.
He wanted everybody else to do well.
So, I think that's a testament
to him and how he lived his life.
But my husband and I go everywhere,
and we hear all kinds of stories
about my father, things
that we would never know.
One thing in particular that we
didn't know, but they told us
that there was a young man
who got drafted to Vietnam,
and he asked for a delay
in going to training camp,
and of course the army told him
no, you know, you have to show up.
So, he left.
He said, "I wanted to, I want
to be here a little bit longer
because my wife is
expecting her first baby."
And they told him no.
So, his parents went to see
my father in his office,
and they told him the
situation, and this man told me,
"In one week I was coming
back to Corpus Christi,
Texas, to stay with my family."
So, one week later the
young man was coming back
because my father had made the
effort to contact whoever needed
to be contacted to make
sure that young man was back
in Corpus Christi with his family.
So, this is, this is what he did,
and he never, he never said anything
to us, and we didn't know what he
was doing, but now I'm going all
over the places, different places,
and I hear all these remarkable
stories, unselfish acts,
where he took the time to help
people and not just as a physician
but other areas where he would,
they would go to his office and wait
to see him, and he would
come out with something.
If someone told him no
the first time, you know,
that wasn't going to stick with him.
He just kept at it
and at it and at it.
So, that's certainly a trait
of his not to ever give up
and to help other people,
and I think he knows that,
he knew that he was put on this
earth to help other people.
He knew that.
We also heard that when he married
my mother in Italy, his parents,
her parents wanted him to stay in
Naples and practice medicine there,
and he would have done
very well there.
He spoke Italian, and he told
my mother, my mother's family
that he could not stay
because he had a mission,
and that mission was in Texas.
He had to get back.
So, he knew back then
in 1945 that he had
to get back to Texas for a mission.
And then he, shortly after that,
he founded the American GI Forum
in 1948, and then we know
shortly after the founding
of the GI Forum was the
Felix Longoria Affair
in Three Rivers, Texas.
Everyone always asks me, "Do
you ever go to Three Rivers?"
and I say no because that
was kind of like his,
that was his first national
effort, and he got on the map
because if you have not heard
about the Three Rivers incident
and Felix Longoria,
there's a documentary
on it called, "The Longoria Affair."
And this young soldier was
killed in World War II,
and his remains came back
to Three Rivers three years
after he was killed.
He was a private, Private Felix
Longoria, and his poor widow went
to Three Rivers and wanted to wake
Felix's body in the one funeral home
that was there, and the funeral
director named Tom Kennedy told her,
"No.
We do not wake Mexicans
in our all-white chapel."
So, she was, of course, devastated.
She was young, she was alone,
she had a young daughter,
so she was told, "Go
contact Dr. Hector Garcia."
So, she did.
She went to see him, and he got on
the phone and called Tom Kennedy
and verified what she
had told him, "Yes.
Now, we don't, we don't
let Mexicans use the chapel
because they're rowdy.
They get drunk and
they get into fights."
So, my father said, "But this young
man gave his life for this country,"
and he said that he didn't care.
So, then my father had a reporter
from the [inaudible] Times call the
funeral director, and he said, "No,"
you know, "they're not going to
let him wake Felix's body there."
So, my father sent out 17 telegrams.
He got one response, and
that was from Senator,
newly-elected Senator
Lyndon Johnson,
who told him that he would
have Felix's body brought
to Arlington National Cemetery
and have him buried there.
So, that was the beginning of
my father's advocacy in 1949,
with the Felix Longoria affair,
that's how he got started
on the national stage.
And Felix is buried here.
He was the first Mexican
American buried
in Arlington National Cemetery.
So, of course, Three Rivers
continues to this day to deny it,
deny the event, my father made it
up, all this other stuff, you know.
We've been kind of a struggle with
some of their residents, even today,
but you know they even accused
my father of causing the death
of that funeral home director
14 years after the event.
So, I mean, they also said that my
father did the Felix Longoria Affair
because he was hoping to receive
the Presidential Medal of Freedom
in 1984 when this was in 1948, which
didn't even, wasn't even created
for what my father received it for.
So, I mean, we've had, we've had
some pretty big fights with some
of them, but I think we prevailed.
We haven't heard from
them in several years.
So, yeah, it was a struggle for
him, but I think everybody can learn
from my father's life
and appreciate it
and really apply what he has
done to our own lives today.
I think that's very, very important,
and there's not too much written
about Mexican Americans
like my father,
and I think that this is a
good, this is a good start,
"The Inspiring Life of
Texan Hector P. Garcia."
And I'm very proud of my book,
and I hope all of you read it
and enjoy it, and I wanted to
read just a little bit from here
that I wrote about
his military life.
"Dr. Hector P. Garcia would
achieve a high rank in the military,
but he would never forget
about the soldiers who fought
with him in World War II.
He felt an obligation to all the
military members he would encounter,
to the organization he
founded, the American GI Forum.
This was clearly evident
during the Vietnam War.
He was very saddened by all the
soldiers who were being returned
to Corpus Christi to their families
after being killed in this war.
He made efforts every day
to comfort the families.
He would be notified when one of
these young men would be returning
to his family in a coffin.
He would make arrangements with
other American GI Forum members
to meet the returning soldiers
at the Corpus Christi
[inaudible] station or the airport,
regardless of the time of day.
If needed, my father would refer
the families to a local funeral home
for interment and funeral
services at a very low cost.
The funeral home was happy
to assist these families
at my father's request.
My father would attend the
funerals of these young men
and would often speak
at their services.
I asked him one morning
why was he going
so early to greet these soldiers.
He had been working an 18-hour day,
well into the night and morning,
taking care of his patients.
He replied, "Because I have to go.
It is the least that
I can do for them."
There was always a sadness in his
eyes when he was getting ready
to leave to greet the soldiers
every morning for the services.
He would not miss any of them.
He felt it was his obligation
to make sure the soldiers
and their families would be
taken care of at this sad time.
Reviewing y father's military
records was a very tedious process.
I am elated that I was able to study
and understand this important aspect
of his life, though in his
determination to succeed,
helped me understand how complex
an individual he really was.
He would never take
no for an answer.
I saw this time and
time again in my life.
We can all look at Major Hector
P. Garcia, MD, as a role model
for the youth and ourselves,
someone who can serve
to instruct our children about the
benefits of a higher education.
We can all learn from his
determination to succeed.
His life in the military is just
one example of a person who desired
to achieve the American Dream,
took responsibility seriously,
and never made excuses for himself
or what was occurring around him.
I have definitely learned in my
lifetime how to persevere and try
to be an example for others.
He had achieved independence
in his life but was also able
to develop lasting
relationships around him.
He understood the values of trust
and love for his fellow man; yet,
he never forgot that he was called
to serve all the people around him
through his medical practice
and by assisting veterans
through the organization he
founded, the American GI Forum."
So, that's what I wrote about him.
There's so much about his
military career and records,
and I want to thank you for today.
Sometimes, it's hard for me to
stand up and talk about my father
because I loved him very much,
and I learned so much from him,
but thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I have some incredible
photographs here that I want
to donate to the Veterans
History Project.
They're original photographs
from World War II,
and I hope that you
enjoy them and use them,
and thank you so much
for this opportunity.
>> Betsy Peterson: Oh, thank
you, thank you very much.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
You're welcome.
>> Betsy Peterson: On behalf of
the Veterans History Project,
we are very proud to receive
this photographic collection
from Ms. Garcia-Akers and
to receive these photographs
from Hector P. Garcia.
These photographs will be stored,
catalogued, and made available
in the Library of Congress
and saved for perpetuity.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Thank you.
>> Betsy Peterson: So that future
generations can come and see
and learn from Mr.
Garcia's experience.
I want to thank you.
I also want to say that the
Veterans History Project has
over 1100 collections from
veterans who identify as Hispanic,
and of those over 1100 collections,
roughly 340 are digitized
and now available.
When donating a collection to
the Veterans History Project,
as with all participating veterans
and individuals that are a part
of the collections here, we
encourage those who are Hispanic
to identify themselves as Hispanic.
By doing so, the historical
evidence is your personal experience
becomes evident.
It won't be lost, and it is
more accurately reflected
in the historical record,
and we need that.
It's very important.
So, Cecilia, again, on behalf
of the Library of Congress
and the Veterans History Project,
thank you for this
incredible collection.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
I didn't know
if anyone had any questions they
want to ask me about the book
or my father's life or anything that
I'll do my best to try to answer.
Does anyone have any questions?
[ Silence ]
>> You mentioned that you've
gotten his military records.
Did you go to other areas, other
libraries, or other institutions
to get more information
on your father?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Well,
fortunately, fortunately, in 1990,
he donated, my father
donated his entire collection
to Texas A&M Corpus Christi.
So, they are in possession of,
you're not going to believe this,
7000 photographs, and
over the length
of a football field in documents.
Now, he never threw away anything,
so as you can tell, but he would,
what he would do every
morning, he would go
and buy the Corpus
Christi Colored Times.
He would buy like three
copies, and he would go and mark
with a felt pen each article.
Like he would say, file under
John Kennedy, or Lyndon Johnson,
or Civil Rights, whatever that
article was he was interested in,
and they would make
scrapbooks and so on.
And you're talking about, yeah,
I think at one time he had wanted
to take care of this cataloguing it,
but it's so massive
that he had to donate.
He didn't have the
resources, not only financial,
but you have to have certain people
to be able to handle these old --
I mean, these pictures that
I've donated are from the 1940s,
and my mother, fortunately,
saved everything also.
So, we have hundreds of photographs
at the house, when they were dating
and when they got married, just
beautiful photographs that,
you know, I intend to
do something with later.
But fortunately, I was
able to go to A & M
and pull all his military
documents and look at them that way,
and separation papers
were very interesting,
and that's where I found
his US citizenship papers.
And I knew that he had
fibbed about that one year,
but because the citizenship papers
were different form the Army
Separation papers, the
dates and where he was born.
So, thank, you know, thank God,
I had those resources
to research his life.
I didn't do a whole lot.
I mean, I did all his
military records
and also the discrimination
case, CCISD, in Corpus Christi
because that was a
big struggle for him.
It took about eight
years, so there was lots
and lots of information on that.
So, that's, and that's how I
did it, and that's what he did.
He just clipped articles, and he,
lots of times he had young children
work in his office, young teenagers
that were getting through high
school, and he would put them
to work, and he'd come
in with the newspapers,
and they would start cutting them
out and putting them in scrapbooks.
There were no computers
back then either, you know.
Yes?
>> There was no congratulations for
producing the manuscript and all
that research in six months.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Yeah.
>> Printing process.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: It was.
It was. I don't know how we did it,
but thank goodness my
husband was here to help me.
>> And I was just wondering if you
had any advice for somebody else
who might want to write a book
about a family member, a memoir,
if you have any advice at
all about that process?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Well,
I, you know, you have to,
it has to come from your heart, you
know, and what I did was, you know,
my business is I'm in the car
driving around to patient's homes
about ten hours a day, so I
had a lot of time to think.
Turn the radio off.
But on Sundays, I would just start
writing, one chapter at a time,
write, write, write, you know,
whatever I could remember.
And then, my dear husband would
type it up for me, and so a couple
of days later I would go and
correct it or add things to it.
But in the car, I would write little
notes or what I wanted to change
or ask myself a question,
what about this?
You know, memories started coming
back to me as I was writing.
I think the hardest part of
writing a book is the organization,
how you want to organize
the chapters.
And of course, the History Press
had their own manuscript guidelines
like how many spaces and how
many words and, you know,
they were very strict about that,
and it had to be on a certain file,
and we had to, you know, send
everything in, and photographs had
to be a certain way, and they had
to be 6 and 1/2 inches in length,
and they, you know, they
wouldn't take any small ones.
So, a lot of them I wanted to use,
a lot of the photographs I wanted
to use, they wouldn't accept
them because they were too small.
Some of them were too grainy.
So, I think it's just, you know,
if you get more than six months,
I think you'd probably do a good
job, but they were in a hurry
to get this book published,
and it was published April 4th.
So, I think it just has to come
from here, to answer your question,
and to organize your thoughts.
Yes?
>> I'm wondering if you
could tell us a little bit
about his relationship
with LBJ, and did he know
about [inaudible] veterans because
I believe they were both involved
in the Civil Rights Movement?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Lyndon
Johnson, you know, they started,
of course, my father was a lifelong
Democrat, you know, he just,
that's just the way he was,
and he supported every Democratic
candidate that ran for President.
Lyndon was, of course, from Texas,
and they became close during
the Felix Longoria Affair
because he was the only
one that would respond
to my father's telegram
about getting some help.
And he told my father that he
has, he cannot control what goes
on in a private funeral
home but that he was going
to have Felix buried in Arlington,
if his widow would accept it.
So, that's how they
developed a relationship.
He became close to him, of course,
after John Kennedy was assassinated.
He was going to the
White House all the time.
He was, as we say today, in
Lyndon Johnson's face, you know,
about certain things, like Civil
Rights, and they became very close,
and my father was not
shy about telling him,
"You're doing a terrible job."
I mean, they had terrible fights,
but they respected each other,
and Johnson finally came around.
You've seen that famous speech that
he gave on the Congressional floor
about his first job was a
school teacher in Kutula, Texas.
You've seen that, haven't you?
And then he says that, he says that
he saw the sadness and the hunger
in his students' eyes every
day as they showed up.
And he would spend his own money to
help give these children breakfast
and take care of them, and
he said, "I never thought
that I would one day have the
chance to help those children
as President of the United States."
They were from Kutula, Texas.
And I think my father had
a big influence on him,
and they had high respect for each
other, but my father never shied
from telling him off,
you know, he never did.
He never did.
And Martin Luther King, a lot
of people ask me about that,
and I just think that they
never really crossed paths,
and a month before Dr. King was
assassinated there was a telegram
that he sent my father telling
him, "I know that you're, you know,
involved in Civil Rights," and he
wanted to set up a meeting with him.
It was a month before the
assassination, so they never did,
they never did have that meeting.
I think my father followed
his career
and followed what he was doing,
but you know my father was
in a different direction as far as
the veterans and Mexican Americans
and Hispanic Civil Rights.
So, I don't think they
really crossed paths.
[ Silence ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
Anybody have any other questions?
>> I have one.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Yes.
>> In what ways are you
most like your father?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
My sister's laughing.
>> I can tell you that.
>> I'm going to let, I'm going
to let my husband answer
that question, right.
I'm going to let him answer for me.
>> Jim Akers: Cecilia always,
she'll get so mad at me
for using this analogy, but most
everyone has heard the saying,
"The apple doesn't fall
too far from the tree."
Well, Dr. Hector was the
tree, and here's the apple.
You know, her memory
is like Dr. Hector's.
He never forgot anything.
I mean, he just, you know, he
always remembered people's names,
all this stuff, and
she's the same way.
I have to be very careful about what
I tell her for the last 40 years
because she remembers everything.
But you know, I think he had a
very big influence on her life,
and their work ethics
are a lot alike.
They don't know when
to stop and, you know,
she doesn't know what rest is.
It's, you know, seven
days a week and, you know,
I'm going till I can't go
any further, and then figure
out some way to keep going.
But she's a product of her father.
There's no doubt about that, and
it's a mostly good product, so.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
He said mostly.
>> Jim Akers: Mostly, probably more
good than, a lot more good than bad,
but you know, it's a great, it's
great for her to be honored,
to be able to do this and write
this story about her father.
And you know, he was such an
influence on her life and a lot
of other people's, but
she's really taken this
and done a great job of
promoting his legacy.
And this all got started by
a promise we made her mother
that we would not let his legacy go
untold, so we tried to keep it up.
Thank you.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
In the book,
I do describe how we got started.
I mean, Jim and I were living
our life privately and, you know,
my mother is at San Antonio
because she had some
serious health problems,
and I felt that I could help her
better there than in Corpus Christi,
which, you know, it
was not an easy time
to move her three different times.
So, she was very difficult
to take care of,
so we did our best, you know.
But she ended up having
six surgeries in two years,
so you know it kept us busy.
But one day she calls me up,
and she's crying on the phone,
and I go, "Momma, what's wrong?"
And she said that she had received
the American GI Forum Newsletter
called, "The Forum."
They were sending out a
quarterly newsletter at the time,
and it was in March, the
founder's month, and she says,
"There's not one picture of papa."
She called him papa.
"There's not one picture
of papa in this book."
I said, "Well, let
me come over there."
So, we went over there,
and she just lived
about seven minutes from my house.
She had a beautiful apartment
that we set her up in
and was well taken care of
till the end of her life.
But we went over there, and to
see your 84-year-old mother crying
like that, and she wouldn't stop.
And that, I think that really
impacted me because she was saying,
"No one knows who papa is.
No one knows what he
did for this country.
No one knows about him,
and the American GI Forum
was not promoting him."
So, that day, we made
a promise to her
that we would do whatever we
needed to to have my father
at the historical level
that he needed to be.
And so that's how we got started,
that one phone call from her.
And to our credit, really, it really
needed to be done by the family
because we knew it needed
to be done correctly.
But you know, he really needs to
be at a different level than he is
and recognized because of
everything that he did.
And there's a bio in the back about
all his accomplishments to date,
and so one thing we didn't put
in there, but it should be,
by the end of the year, he's
going to be on the Points
of Light Monument, probably
by the end of this year.
So, that's something else that
we're going to be working on,
Points of Light Monument.
But that's how we got started,
and it's a promise to momma,
and I think we've done
a pretty good job.
Yes?
>> Are there any other questions?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Yes.
>> We had a meeting on at a
very interesting moment now
with policies, alias.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Yes.
>> What would be your father's
point of view or [inaudible]
like you said, he [inaudible].
So, what would be your father's
if you see him now if you brought
up any of these candidates?
What would be their [inaudible]
to like he was [inaudible]?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: I
think, you know, if you ask,
if you ever have a chance
to look at the documentary,
"Justice for my People,"
they did a really good job
about my father's life,
and they had some clips
of him attacking the Superintendent
of Corpus Christi's School District
and saying that he had to go.
I mean, he was not shy about what he
thought, but I think as far as this,
all this, this fear
about immigration
and the immigrants are taking jobs
away, and I think, I think he,
I mean, he is an immigrant,
and so was my mother.
And I always point that out,
they were both immigrants
to this country, and look
how they lived their lives.
I mean, it's like the fear that
people are getting away with,
putting it to the residents,
the citizens of this
country, is just so unfounded.
He would, I can assure
you he would be
on national news every single day
attacking whoever he needed to
and clearing up what was
right and what was wrong.
He would be doing that
every single day.
He wouldn't, he would be, he
had great, from back then,
he had great media coverage, and
that's what he would be doing.
He would be meeting
individually with Donald Trump,
he would, and Hilary Clinton.
He would be there, and I'm sure
by now he would have
had multiple meetings
with President Obama, I'm sure.
I am sure of that.
So, I think that he knew the
right path for this country,
and I think he would be
right now very disappointed
in the way it's going.
Yes?
>> I'd like to talk
about the GI Forum.
I appreciate it has more to do
with veterans groups like GI Forum.
Younger veterans today
tend to stay away
from traditional organizations
[inaudible] American Legion.
Do you see a role for those
[inaudible] organizations today,
or do you think they sort of
outlived their usefulness in terms
of advancing the veterans'
interests?
Not only Mexican Americans,
but overall?
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: I
think you made a good point.
I don't think that they've
outlived their usefulness.
I think they're direction
is not like the same as,
especially the American GI Forum,
they don't really recruit new
members from more recent wars.
They kind of stick
with the old guard.
I don't see a whole lot of new
members signing up, which is a shame
because they have different needs.
You know, I have had many, many
patients coming back from the war.
They're just, I mean, they're
injuries are just so profound that,
you know, I'd never seen them
before on older patients,
and I think they're
not addressing that.
I don't think they're addressing
their educational needs.
I think since my father died,
American GI Forum, they've just,
they have not really
developed any strong leadership
on a national level,
and they're broke.
They don't have any money.
And you need money to really
promote an organization to do well.
But I, you know, I just
think that [sigh] it's more
like a social organization, you
know, where they have hamburgers,
sell them, or whatever,
that kind of thing.
But you don't really see
them advocating for veterans
on a national level, and
I think that's a shame.
And I think, I think,
no, they're not done,
but I think their problem lies
in not having strong leadership,
educated leaders, to
take up the cause,
and I think that's
been their problem.
[ Silence ]
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: Sure.
And this is strictly my
opinion, but I've seen it, so.
>> He had a mind.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers: And
his, and we've lived it, so.
Yes?
>> Well, I was just going to
ask everyone if you wanted
to have some refreshments
and thank Ms. Garcia-Akers,
and to get a coffee at the
desk and talk some more
with her and get her autograph.
>> Cecilia Garcia-Akers:
Oh, no, thank you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.